folks we might be drunk is brought to
you by sheath underwear the official
underwear of Comedy what do you got
uh oh he's got it usually you're only
wearing women's panties I just assume
I'm wearing it that's what sheath wears
they make women's pads true that's true
I could I could get my little panty line
support from a [__] war hero yeah
have your time having your dick stuck to
your balls and your balls stuck to your
leg and your legs stuck to your dick
it's time to try sheath it has two 80s
have dicks now too that's true good
point you're right we don't discriminate
two pouches one for the dawn one for the
ball sheath underwear comes in tons of
cool patterns to help you look and feel
comfortable you know we love it we're
wearing them right now it really is the
best underwear it's the best I have a
friend who whenever he's over he's like
do you have extra and sometimes I do and
I give it to him and he's like that's a
that's a good because he's like I want
it but it's expensive and I was like
it's not that it's for what you're
getting it lasts oh yeah I gave outside
Steve like 10 pairs really yeah because
I had so many and he's taller than me so
I was like these gonna fit go nuts
so uh they didn't leave out the ladies
either shoot those boys short sports
bras bikini briefs go to sheet.aware.com
use promo code drunk to get 20 off your
first order every order comes with
cheats 100 money back guarantee that's
sheet underwear.com promo code drunk
good sheathed underwear and let them
support your balls
let's do it are you rolling
no uh bartender today no Salamanca yes
the teacher's away and the mice will
play you got that right I don't think
that was the expression the cats away
that's it close enough but we got some
Mark vodka sodas yeah made them strong
it's a beautiful day it's 60 degrees in
New York global warming love it hit me
push it hard this weekend but I'm having
a great day I helped two people in New
York how do you help them uh a blind
lady fell in the street on 6th Avenue
and I ran to savor picked her up she was
all old and [__] up and I got I called
her a cab and then uh on the way here uh
an old I hope she doesn't listen to this
podcast
it's not really helping she was all old
and disgusting I saved her she had snot
bad dressed you know
um so yeah I helped her got her a cab
and then on the way here I ran out of
the subway and there was an old lady on
top with a bag and she was like and I
was like let me get the bag and I took
the bag and I ran it down
he was an old bag
but don't you just feel it you want
people to see that I'm like where
where's all my haters I want you to see
me helping these old you do hope someone
sees it yeah that's when you want to get
recognized exactly you never get
recognized when you want to I know it's
always you coming out of like a [__]
porn store and you're like I went in as
a joke right right yeah why are you hard
Wait no that's part of the joke I commit
yes yes no it's uh I know you mean man I
I had a guy uh stop me the other day on
the street and he was like uh he just
kind of you know when it's coming he
like gave me a lug and I was like I give
him like a hello yeah and then he uh
then he goes Josh Hart for the Knicks
and I was like it's a good signing I
like it and then he goes I have a
startup and I'm like oh here we go oh no
you blew it we had a thing it was a good
thing thing yeah never ask for things
folks it's all gravy until you start
going I have a script you gotta read it
or I want you to be in this or whatever
and you're like damn it now I gotta say
no to you I know yeah what's up with
this one I had a show in Spokane great
show great clubs did you go to Frank's
Diner I went to Frank's Diner great dime
and a boxcar yes amazing amazing it was
a line too but we went to the classic
veter fought for that one and we're on
the road he's like we gotta go to
Francis let's go it's great it's great
old school the other one the greasy
spoon what's the other satellite's a
good one too oh it's okay it's got some
clutch diners yeah well it's like a work
in town you know a lot of blue collar
people go in there but had this one
crowd that sucked and then I do the Q a
at the end and they're going how's your
how's the house coming in Brooklyn
what's up with your watch beeping they
knew everything about me I'm like you
guys know me you're the biggest fans you
know more about me than my father and
you're the worst crowd isn't that the
weirdest thing well that's like our
greatest fear is like one once they get
to know you they're no longer really
invested
I think they were just like oh this is
cool we're seeing him in front of us but
they weren't like haha now I've had that
a couple times in the row where they
just want to be there it's like I feel
like someone's podcasting is ruining
stand-up yeah yeah because they want to
talk to you they don't want to watch you
right but I do think most of the shows
are still no killer but occasionally I
get that feeling yeah seven out of eight
were great but like David tell would be
like podcasts are running it's
definitely the Colin Quinn's of the
world yeah yeah but they also help so
much they have tickets and and you get
to know the fans get to know you more so
they know your humor more yeah so no
it's it's a double-edged sword but uh
yeah I was in Salt Lake with uh Gary we
did we hit it up man we did it right tan
France uh got a little lunch with tan
France who said it'll come on the Pod so
I'm gonna hold them please come on here
we want him on I need his help with my
special I don't know what to wear you
should hit him up I'm worried he's gonna
be too
fashiony no I I think you say what you
want and he gets you a cooler version of
what you want all right that's his job
Danny let's do it yeah yeah he's that's
what he does he's the he's the fashion
guy all right all right I need him guys
my favorite part of that show queer eye
is when uh the guy is like uh you know I
hated gay people before and now I you
know I realize they're really cool and
like you know not all gay people are
just gonna fix your life
that's not how old gay people are right
they're not Guardian Angels they're gay
they're annoying gay people too that's
true these are just they were hired to
help right right I think they are gays
have some uh equalities that make them
better than the typical straight guy oh
yeah that fashion of Kong shui and uh
you know decorating there if you're not
ripped as a gay guy now I'm kind of like
what are you doing yeah it's like a
black guy with a small dick it's it's
tough yeah come on man I had a friend
growing up black guy who couldn't dance
wow and it was a ruined his life he was
just like we'd have dance parties or go
to the bar and you know white guys can
go out there and do this [__] and nobody
bats an eye because they're like he's a
white guy but if the black guy is going
like this it's a bad look yeah I had a
black friend growing up who sucked at
basketball oh it crushed him it crushed
him he played really hard on D but it
was to make up for the fact that there
was no offensive ability of course I
grew up with a dumb Asian he was a drug
addict he was an idiot anyway we were
like what are you doing you're Asian
he's like I know it sucks this whole
string of uh stereotypes is called uh
we're gonna get canceled we're gonna get
demonetized on YouTube yeah no you know
it's uh I knew a gay guy now
it was horrible he couldn't get he
couldn't get any dick his name was Matt
salacus
but uh yeah no it's like ripped gay
dudes although you go to the gym and
it's like
you can hook up at the gym I know I
can't hook up at the gym no no I see hot
women at the gym and I can't like
sometimes I'll get like a hello or
something and you're like hey but you're
like I don't have you know I see like
sometimes a trainer at the gym I go to
will be like friendly and she's hot yeah
but in my head I'm like but you look at
me like I'm [__] of course like it's
it's like if we saw uh Open Mic comic
right right you're not dazzling anyone
with that part of you yeah good point
but is she like I'm the fitness person
so I kind of like that you're not maybe
because you don't want to date up Open
Mic comic because that's just too much
comedy although you've dated Comics so
have I so maybe that's no good no it's
tough uh but yeah it's yeah no you're
right maybe that's not what but I just
think like they're so good at that yeah
like you're a [__] right don't you just
need like a shredded giant dude yeah
that's true you'd think that's a tough
one but then she's probably not funny
and you're funny so maybe that fills out
yeah as long as the hole is being filled
I'm happy yeah there we go can I redo
some peeves okay because we haven't done
peeves I've got a list all right all
right uh so I'm at the cellar with Ryan
Hamilton the other night a good friend
of ours and Ryan's got a brilliant new
chunk about getting hit by a bus which
is amazing really hit by a bus yeah it's
a crazy story it's uh it's cool to watch
that type of bit kill at the seller yeah
it's a long bit that's pretty [__]
depressing that he's just killing with
totally we're walking late at night and
some woman sneaks up behind us as we're
crossing the street and she goes a bus
is coming and we're like Jesus and I'm
like he was actually hit by a bus he's
got PTSD was she joking it doesn't
matter the damage is done wow so what
did he do just he freaked out oh my Lord
he was just like I mean it was like half
a second but then she's like bowled over
laughing I'm like guess what that's not
a good joke yeah there are three people
here and two of them don't think it's
funny yeah that's a good point but she's
but he's you know you could tell he's
like what the [__] but yeah wow that's
heavy yeah but how far does it go if
you're like uh Ryan's you're at dinner
with him and he's like ah these plates
need to come clear and you're like oh
here comes a bus boy ah [__] he's
busting table like where does it end
well that it ends it ends there I think
in a restaurant I think you're okay all
right all right I think on the street
you're like this really happened to him
he nearly was killed yeah all right
whatever he's in the hospital for Dave
for many days I know he was all [__]
up um he's still a little I think he's
still a little wonky that's a peeve by
the way also is uh
is the haha as a it was a joke yeah the
prank joke the prank joke's not really a
joke totally like when a guy would hit
you in the balls and he'd be like I
gotcha Impractical Jokers work because
they're all in on it right they're like
we know we're gonna get [__] over yeah
but when you're just doing it to a
stranger
you're kind of a piece of [__] that's
true yeah and you're the only one
laughing yeah joke's not funny like our
set doesn't work if we're just like just
us and they're just like we don't we
don't get it you hear that Chappelle
laughing at your own jokes I would say
it's all Comics out there but yeah yeah
no I agree
she got one it's it's the same with this
move yeah you know that whole thing or
this one you know whatever this one if
it's like a hot girl you're like all
right she's flirting that's true I'll
take it if I yeah I take this back if a
woman does any of these things it's okay
because it means she's flirting and in
her defense she didn't know about the
bus thing
can't do that with rape no yeah it's a
guy with the ski mask
yeah exactly boy that's tough that's
pretty shitty yeah pretty shitty yeah
she should blow him and he's like I'm
about to bust all right I hope she gets
hit by a bus
that'd be hilarious we're just like well
Karma what do you got you got a peeve
Karma busma okay uh Marcus committed to
this pun yes he's making this pun work
how about this yeah
what about the guy who gives too many
handshakes I hate the too many handshake
what are we doing you know he comes in
we're having dinner hey how are you man
all right good to meet you yeah yeah
he's like just gotta say a big fan of
your car oh yeah all right all right all
right we're heading out hey okay and
keep putting out more stuff man don't
change I'm like all right we've shaken
hands four times it's been three minutes
this Jericho's running for mayor all of
a sudden just come in and shake a
[__] hand I know I did I was gonna
get a Purell mug after this guy I was
like this is enough that's the thing
it's like it's a drunk usually it is he
was drunk It's a drunk the drunks need
constant validation I think that's why
it's annoying because they're constantly
being like more that's what it is look
at me yeah kids in the pool that are
like Mommy but as an adult and I'm not
your [__] mom I know so I just
started switching to this because this
is a lot you know it's it's kind of
you're touching Palms I get a little
sweat there this some it's easy so I
just switched over after the fourth one
to pounding yeah but that I know what
you mean you get a lot of those you
sometimes you get this guy the over
complimenter who's drunk yeah I think
you're great man you're like thank you
and he's like no I really like you and
you're like I like you too and they're
like they're like well I think you're
I'm like guess what I don't like you
anymore yeah yeah too much I don't know
where to go but the fourth one you've
told me I'm funny I don't know what else
to say thank you again appreciate it
yeah I don't know then you seem
ungrateful it's a tough well the guy
who's that drunk if someone's that much
past your level there's no connecting
because they're not going to remember
any of this [__] yeah they're so far
past you you're kind of like well I'm
just having to wait it's like talking to
a guy who just lies to you all the time
right we're just like well none of this
is real and none of this is registering
so you're just like this is kind of a
waste yeah I hooked up with a girl years
ago we were in the back seat of a car
making out and she was so hot she was
like way out of my league and I couldn't
stop bringing it up because I was
insecure and eventually she was like
stop telling me I'm hot and I was like
all right all right I'm just kissing her
necklace are you sure yeah yeah but like
I would pull away and I was like God
you're gorgeous I was drunk too
every once in a while you pull a fish
that's a little too big yes yeah like
how did I I pulled a lot of big fish but
I'm just saying she she was like a hot
lady like a like a modely hot lady in
L.A and I couldn't stop saying it and
she had to tell me to stop and I was
turning her off because she kept
realizing how big of a deal this was for
me oh that's hilarious yeah you blew it
by acting like you've never been there
yes exactly I didn't I didn't end up
banging her you have to nag the you have
to be it's like a model you have to be
like I mean you're okay yeah yeah I've
seen better she would have loved that
yeah so yeah I got
kicked out of that that Uber damn yeah I
need an Uber no it wasn't an Uber but I
was just saying I we were in the back
seat of her car and eventually she was
like I gotta get going I was like all
right
yeah I've definitely they can tell if
it's too big a deal oh yeah oh yeah and
let me ask you this you ever hooked up
with a girl Then followed her on
Instagram just so you can see her more
I don't think so ah me neither
that's just you're like you want to
remind yourself like every time it pops
up oh you know you're like oh yeah
hooked up with her I have to check your
follows oh yeah
he's following his aunt I mean Dan hell
in the bottom Carter that's a weird one
uh no we uh sometimes I just want to
watch the world burn I don't like
sometimes you get a DM from from a
private account and I'm like what are
you insane
yeah that's annoying a DM from a private
account yeah I was talking to Jared
freed who's like a relationship Guru
he's great he gives great advice and he
was put them on here we got to get him
on here we got to do like a dating
episode that'd be because he's so good
at that yeah
his whole Act is like a dating thing
yeah I mean he's got other stuff too but
he but we were at a bar the other night
and uh it's hilarious I was already
drunk and then freed showed up oh I'm
toast it's over it's over I was drunk
and he he just goes where are you and I
told him and he just he just like walks
in I was like how did you get here
quickly and uh he's that he's a drunk
you know when you drink with someone
every time you turn around they're
handing you enough yes that's him I'm
like how the [__] like he's a pro this
is like the old west how quick you are
yeah you turn around he's polished on
the bar you know no he is that guy he
can drink he can party he knows he moved
to the village and I bumped into him I
live in the village and he was like uh I
already got where I'm gonna eat every
day I know where all these bar he mapped
it all out he's like a real organized
drunk he's great and he knows every bar
to go to and he knows every bar at what
time yes yes impressive thing like it's
one thing to know a good bar when he
goes this one takes off around 2 A.M
totally I was bombed I had to almost
sneak out it was freezing I just saw you
ever do this I just saw a cab yeah it
was like 4 a.m I just gunned for it
gotta do it but you know it's the only
way because he'll give you another shot
he [__] goes hard you need a lot of
Jews who are tanks like that yeah well
he's uh Boston I think he was in a frat
so he's had the Jew pushed out of him he
went to Penn State and he went to Penn
State come on so he he drank away the
the semitism
how about uh hotels where you have to
turn on 40 lamps to make the room bright
oh I hate that how about one control
light I completely agree you know I hate
lamps we were in like a cool hotel and
it wasn't like fancy or anything it was
just like one of those cool hotels yeah
and uh geez I don't even remember where
the hell we were Portland and we're in a
cool hotel we walk in I swear to God
I had to run around the room the worst
still dark still dark and they're trying
to be too boutiquey and too hip you know
they want all these hand-picked lamps
this is from Nicaragua this is from a
thrift store you know this is a cat with
the eyes like come on none of what this
is the eyes it's too much they're trying
so hard to be quirky that there's no you
can't do any writing that's what it's
too quirky yeah it's like a hipster
who's like you're like we get it you
[__] were into the band before right
you know you only watched foreign films
that's what you are is a hotel yeah I
know I'm gonna jerk off in here take a
big dump and [__] a fat fish just give
me a lamp give me a light it's like you
ever see the guy with like the the faux
hawk yes that's that is a hotel
yeah this doesn't even look good it's
just you want me to notice you yeah
exactly exactly and quirky is the
opposite of efficient efficient is like
some uh nerdy autistic guy who's like
this is the lamp it goes in the middle
of the ceiling one switch turns it on
it's eight million kilowatts quirky is
like ooh we're gonna be on Pinterest
they have one of those little uh sand
things with the rake that does nothing
you know that thing what is that that
meditation
zen garden thank you pull it up what
does that look like pull it up that's so
pointless but it's you know I never
meditate everyone tells me to meditate I
never do it I've tried and the worst
thoughts I've ever had came up but I
never did it again I pay the I pay for
one of them it's headspace or something
yeah headspace I tried that I pay for it
I might have just unsubscribed but it
was uh it was it was not pricey but
pricey enough that I was like I should
do this yes you ever just spend enough
where you're like I'll do this because
it's enough money that I'll feel guilty
and I just still didn't do it totally
yeah [__] that I tried it too and
I got like a day and it feels good when
you do it it does I should do it it
takes a little discipline we should we
should try it we should try it yeah
because all the most brilliant people
meditate I'm so bored
wonders too much I even I'll try to do
yoga sometimes on the road just to like
stretch out after all the flying and I'm
so bored yeah I'm excited that's someone
telling you what to do but it's all
these holes and I'm just like what am I
doing but maybe the boredom we need to
fight it may we need to go lean into the
boredom because we're so good at
grabbing a phone or putting on TV or
whatever are you telling me I'm hiding
from something
but I think it is a skill if you can
overcome that that's you've really
conquered something yeah you're right I
mean that's probably why guys like Jerry
seem so disciplined yeah because they
forced them so I know a lot of writers
who do that [__] athletes Brian
koppelman are boy Brian yeah another one
totally yeah and then do you ever think
this now we're getting heavy but I was
watching this dolphin documentary and a
guy was a busboy and he was staring
through a fence at this water park
looking at dolphins in his like the 70s
and he became the biggest dolphin
trainer in the world
what if he had a cell phone in the 70s
he might not even notice the Dolphins
you know what I'm saying they're just
staring at his phone and tick-tocking
and hot girls twerking and uh you know
memes
but now he's got no phone he's just
staring at Dolphins 70s I think about
that all the time like Riders like
Hemingway if they had like people they
would if they had their friends being
like look at this cat video yes yes do
you think he would have ridden The Sun
Also Rises [__] no he probably also
wouldn't have blown his brains out but
yeah you're right I mean you had to
figure something out like when I was a
kid you'd go outside with with my
brother and we would just pick up a
stick and hit each other or make a game
out of it or a wizard or whatever the
[__] we sound old right now but there's
truth to it yes yes there's something
about the also Nick Griffin you said
this great bit I love he has so many of
my favorite bits but uh Nick Griffin had
a joke where he uh he said like I think
it's Romeo and Juliet they or West Side
Story whatever same [__] they lost guys
from across the room right you know he
goes with cell phones he's like he's
like you know you're trying to make eye
contact you're like what do you do when
you're like you're my soul mate that's
such a relatable that's killer and he's
good I mean people do meet online but it
is different I always feel better when I
see someone in person like I met a girl
in a bar the other night and I was like
this is like [__] a throwback that's
huge how often do you even do that
anymore I know I know and it's it's so
normal to not do that now that doing
that is weird almost it is weird yeah by
the way shout out to not just you but
also previous guest um Allison Bree and
her buddy Ron on hershberg who have all
told me now to see Defending Your Life I
watched it oh it's a mirror it's great
it's amazing poignant funny poignant
interesting very good Rip Torn I know
he's the greatest he's the man and
Albert Brooks is a genius uh so good
Meryl Streep yeah does she ever is she
ever not great ah she's great and they
don't make movies like that anymore it's
such a high concept idea it's kind of
like Groundhog Day where like you can be
it could you could take your time yeah
right they don't make movies like that
now you got to hit them so quickly I
watched the Pam Anderson doc too I watch
that I think it's pretty good yeah yeah
it humanizes early it organizes it oh
man
but same old story molested beaten bad
dad shitty you know family and then you
you meet Tommy Lee and you're like this
is just her dad yeah it's so crazy
similar I was trying to do a new bit uh
the other night about how uh every
relationship I've ever been in when a
woman's yelling at me it's like the
opposite of Star Wars I'm just like I am
not your father
oh that's great that's great when you're
drunk you sound like Yoda
the condom broke it did
you know uh yeah he's her dad it's sad
it's like you do and then when she said
at one point in the dark not to spoil it
but I don't think I'm giving away a ton
here she basically said uh
she basically said like I never made
peace with the fact that I couldn't make
it work with the father of my kids I was
like [__] that's brutal because she got
married like five times after that she
did yeah I didn't get that far four or
five times after that Kid Rock was one
of them ah I remember that one there was
a few yeah that's sex tape really [__]
her up well he got he got like you know
props for it almost yeah when you're a
rock star that's cool that's true when
you're a woman it's just not cool not
cool unless you're Kim Kardashian I
guess like she she popped like the right
time I guess with it and she put hers
out purposely they say damn and it but
she she had a play Screech
you know Screech was like this one's
gonna [__] yeah he's gonna bring me
back
did did he stab a guy I think he got
stabbed oh he got stabbed wow that's
more believable yeah I don't know what
happened but that's true damn Screech
was really that's like such a weird
American story I know like the kind of
the dweeb on the show yeah you're the
[__] up one yeah oh wait he did stab
oh he stabbed the guy yeah well I think
he's got a ruin he's got to get rid of
that old image he said stabbing that
doesn't mean he's that's true former
child was sentenced four Once yeah on
Christmas day in a bar fight in
Wisconsin what is that a country song
can you imagine getting killed your
friend's like what happened Screech
screed stabbed him oh man that's brutal
he should have gone Time Out
Mr Belden shot him dude it's a building
shadow man damn I love that show so did
I watch it all the time so you never yep
I even watched the Miss Bliss years and
I watch the College Years Miss Bliss was
[__] oh yeah she was just a good
person and a good teacher yeah she cared
right right and then this colleges were
hot because they were older yeah you
know Kelly Kapowski was like a woman
damn shoes
hot woman hot lunch you got breast
implants too at the end and it really
stand on breast implants I know I like
ours yeah I don't I I prefer real but
breast implants look so good in clothing
you know when you're when you're feeling
them you're like man is it kind of hard
as a rock and it takes you out of it a
little bit but when you see him in a
shirt I think a wrapped gift uh-huh yeah
the rapping is nice but then you undo it
you're like what do we do we need this
paper yeah good point good point but a
real tit it's a it's actually it's like
getting cash yeah you know this is good
all around
thanks Bob
tit coin they're gone yeah that was uh
yeah I was never in a certain Pierce
nipples freaked me out too I don't love
Pearson I don't love them the only the
only thing good about Pierce Morgan I
mean nipples is you see him in a shirt
and you're like this girl's fun like you
see him through the shirt you're like
she's cool but I don't love them
in person oh I remember live I was in uh
Springfield Missouri and I had DeVito
with me and you see on comic Liam Nelson
and Liam is like seven feet tall he's uh
he's got these four girls coming out and
he's like I've got four chicks coming
I'm like this is hilarious he's just
hosting the show trying to get laid I'm
like just like bringing me back yeah
good for him and he's like pointing them
out to me and I'm on stage I'm like
afterwards I'm like dude I could see one
of them's pierced nipples from like 40
feet away that's like a little
aggressive yeah yeah they know what
they're doing yeah so you're like that's
just a hot look I don't care who you are
oh the Cuomo that was a that was a real
uh 180. these nipples you never knew
that yeah I blocked it out oh yeah
what is he thinking he is a weird dude
he's single he was like a sex guy you
know he was a [__] guy [__] yeah but
we don't we don't need to know that
about our politicians I agree can you
imagine if you just found out like
Elizabeth Warren had a pierced [__] he'd
be like what are we doing what are we
doing here
that's hilarious it's just a lot
Pelosi's got a bad trap stamp it's like
a stock market thing
um yeah he really did he really [__]
his brother's life up too huh yeah yeah
he said he almost killed himself that's
like that's like a uh it's like almost
like a succession level thing where like
you kind of just kind of do right by
your brother and then he [__] your life
over I know and it was the Andrew Cuomo
during the beginning of the pandemic I
was staying at the the ladies house or
their parents in Boston Cape Cod damn
and we would watch the Cuomo thing every
day it was like it was like an old uh
50s thing where we all come together
around the TV and listen you know people
thought he was going to be the
Democratic nominee either like he's
gonna take over can you imagine if he
was President yeah oh my God nipple
rings up on the podium that's insane
it's got a whip there's a girl deck the
first lady's ball gagged
yeah that was why and then well there's
no first lady he would he would have
been I guess the first president to win
with a single president
yeah yeah you're right holy [__] it's a
different girl every year speech yeah
just [__] horse damn that would be
easier when you're dealing with foreign
leaders though you just are like I
brought some [__] out and they're like
this guy's all right it's like Liam
there's no but you know Biden's going
he's like let me check in with Jill real
quick yeah that's true of course he
whipped also we don't have to pretend to
like their book oh Michelle Obama wrote
a book all right no first lady no no
book
but all these girls were tick-tocking I
remember about how much they thought
Andrew Cuomo was hot I know they were
like he's so sexy he's taking charge
he's a real man and then women get duped
yeah I mean he also like how often do we
do this with the media where like they
just will raise up this guy who's like a
hero and then it turns out to be like
Michael avenatti oh he was huge he was
people women were like I want to
there were people like this guy rules
and now he's like a con man who's got
millions of dollars but that's what the
media does they will build its ratings
it's like yeah it's like a TV show it's
like this will be our hero this totally
season and they do it with bad guys too
some guys aren't actually that bad but
they'll just go ah he's evil he's evil
he's great it's like pro wrestling I'm
with you man Putin seems all right if
you get to know him
well like Ukraine is full of Nazis and
all this [__] we're like oh you're we're
supposed to like Ukraine all right you
know it's like it is like a series yeah
nobody's perfect but we make some people
Heroes and some people villains and yeah
they keep flipping and flopping any
other peeves yeah I got another one now
I hope I haven't brought this up before
but you know me I'm an aisle guy on a
flight love the aisle but
I hate the guy with the window shade
open but look he got the window seat so
it's his window I get it but here's my
beef
windows open it's
Florida it's 8 A.M just piping sunbeams
coming in there like crazy yeah he's
asleep on the wall now the beam doesn't
even hit him but it hits everybody else
yeah I see people with two rows behind
me going like this [__] it's [__]
Cyclops it's awful it's brutal the
morning move it's a dick move in the
morning it's a dick move and I don't
think he realizes because he's off
nuzzled on the wall and the windows in
front of him he should realize he should
so that's part of being a decent member
of society is realizing exactly and I'm
being I'm kind of being passive aggress
I'm putting like the menu in my glasses
like trying to build a wall on my uh on
my face so I can't get any sun I've got
the hood up over half my face and
eventually I couldn't take it anymore
and I leaned over him while he was
asleep and I slowly put the shame
quietly and two people were like wow so
I got like some approval but I couldn't
take it guys obsessed with the wall guys
I see the Wall Works it [__] works
you've used that it does block things
out yeah yeah yeah it worked for that
but no it's uh it's a dick move here's
another dick move on morning flights is
the loud guy oh yes even if you're not
trying to sleep that's a [__] bad
energy in the morning totally totally
the guy you ever have the guy I heard
this he's just talking in the pipe he's
talking to the flight attendant rather
he's he's going uh did you bring a food
on the flight did you bring food like
very loud and he's like oh uh yeah yeah
I got food and he's like you eat what we
eat and he's like no I brought my own
thing I'm always like they don't feed
you and I'm like oh give this guy a
[__] humanitarian award [__] you
we're all trying to sleep yeah piece of
[__] I know and you could go they don't
feed you that's crazy but you have to go
oh they don't feed you you want us to
know you're a good person but we think
you're a piece of [__] yes yes it's
backfired I'm with you I had the guys
why don't you peel them off at 20 a
piece of [__] good point you give him a
fruit snack but uh I had the guy two
guys behind me two rows behind me going
like oh where you from I love Cincinnati
it went twice last year just just talk
to them you can't just go oh yeah I love
Cincinnati it's great breakdown the
Bengals Joe burrow goes keep that [__]
yeah [__] the loud voice in the
morning there's a it's also just a voice
in public yeah the person so it's people
who have nothing interesting to say who
are that loud right so used to
overcompensating we know some comedians
who do that they get louder with a with
the the less funny I remember it listen
I won a flight years ago and uh we were
kind of across from each other and we
were just surrounded by dudes on a
bachelor party they were all in polo
shirts and all of them were just like
high-fiving yeah I was in the middle
they're like high-fiving through me they
just keep high-fiving generally this is
brutal and they're all in the same Polo
yes yes I've seen that and they're in
the same Publishers and one of them
takes one out and hands it to a guy and
he's like dude they just keep
high-fiving like what is this I know and
then you they look they act like you're
some kind of square because you're not
getting involved with them and you're
like I don't know you guys I hate that
[__] be a great scene in a movie the
high-fiving and then they they order a
ton of drinks on the plane and then when
the plane lands they have to clap for
some reason [__] you hey I hate the clap
although I was in a flight in Africa
once and it was the most rinky-dink
plane and when that thing landed I not
only clapped I like did the I like faced
Mecca and did this [__] I kissed the
runway it was because it was made out
with a flight attendant I mean Sully
would have been like I'm not flying that
thing damn it was wild yeah we had some
bad turbulence on the way back from Utah
and veter's texting me he's like I'm
next to a woman who is having a
full-blown panic attack oh she's
screaming I was laughing so [__] hard
Crazy by the way veterans opening for my
special he's the best I'm pretty excited
he will expect top shelf uh food though
okay I can handle that it will be he
will be demanding some good meals
all right all right literally every
taxes you better take me out fancy
tonight [__] yeah every text from him
it's funny when people are sober they
have to find some other way to get joy
the gym and eating really well yeah
gadgets I know people would love gadgets
who are sober yeah they're like have you
gotten the new uh electric blanket that
plays music I'm like get the hell out of
here electric blanket dude you know what
I got another wreck for you and this is
gonna sound really dumb but gut health
gut health because we like look you're
doing the athletic greens now I'm doing
it now yeah they're just and this is
part of being a drinker I guess where is
I will have like you know a bottle and a
half of wine and then I wake up the next
day and I have you know uh some kimchi
and I think I always say yeah you know
but [__] like that supposed to be really
healthy kimchi or you know anything
that's just like everyone I talk to
who's really into health is like gut
health is health and we do a lot to [__]
up our guts oh yeah it's all good well
so what what is it a pill is it a powder
anything I mean just anything to take
care of your gut just like Health you
know eat well anything like this okay I
think pickled stuff is good right oh
really pickle is by the way that's how
you know you're getting older when
you're like give me some pickled food
yeah no kid is like are these pickled
beets you know that's true adults love
veg I love pickled food I do too but I
think our livers are pickled I don't
know if that helps
the fruits and veggies okay diverse food
I do that what else you got veggies I do
a lot of veggies fruit you do a lot of
beans yeah yeah fermented foods that's
what I was saying wow yogurt yeah yo
Greek yogurt's good oh all right all
right yeah maybe I'll start doing more
kombucha probiotics because boots is
what it's just all sugar and [__] we get
enough sugar like I think about how much
sugar we take in just from like I do so
much wine on the road oh yeah and I I
can't resist a Manhattan oh no negroni's
man had Negroni at a good was it Minetta
the other night with Rachel Feinstein
we're just Downing negroni's so [__]
good oh yeah so far late night yeah it's
a great one it's dead it's funny too
because that block is kind of trashy you
know it's like off the wagon and all
these shitty food cookie joints beer
pong yeah then you go there and it's
like this sexy ass Jazzy Vibe we got a
little beer pong map of this dude you
and me versus someone I'm up down we're
in let's do it look that's that's that
what I can do breastfeed for at least
six months if you can
that's hilarious damn women have it hard
oh just a little baby sucking on your
nipple I know that's chew oh my God you
see breasts after that though oh yeah
the damage is done it's bad news it
looks like an old eraser
remember David tells joke uh women you
have drinks coming out of you
if men had drinks coming out of their
nipples what would it be beer I'm
driving along my buddy's sucking my
nipple we hit a bump now he's sucking my
dick
the king
it's big in a way I think we got a we
got a surprise guest popping in and any
minute now did you give him the intro or
the info
yeah I think I did let me just double
check see if he texted
oh yeah you got spots tonight
uh I just got asked to do one but I
don't know if I'm gonna I need a night
off every once in a while yeah
I hear that doing an hour at the seller
tomorrow oh I'm doing one tonight yeah
they're good I just like but then the
second I have a night off I'm like what
am I gonna do yeah I don't know should I
do it I know you're gonna say yes I
would say it's just because
what else you gonna do and you can do
one set and still watch a movie still
have dinner like one set isn't really
gonna ruin us a man [__] it all right
there we go I have no life yeah is he
good is our guest all right yeah yeah he
had the right address wait
no wait what was it 251
West 30 oh I don't want to give the
address away or do I [__] it send us
stuff
yeah I was in Spokane got to get Belzer
on this wall man oh bells are rip P all
right Peter Richard Belzer how was Utah
Utah was great man I love uh I love
little Salt Lake action I mean you get
those
you know the Mormons are very
interesting so you either get the
ex-mormons who look like they're in the
Ramones or you get the current Mormon
who look like Kenneth from 30 Rock it's
a nice little range but uh you get it
you get a nice mix and their energy is
great man do they drink there oh yeah
because when you have a 1am uh Closing
Time bars you gotta [__] get lit you
gotta do it man there was one guy in the
front row I [__] you not he had 12
drinks on his table and he was
completely coherent wow that's when you
know it's a problem yeah when you're not
even phased and apparently he's like a
well-known ski instructor or something
oh wow but he would just put him the
[__] back yeah no Salt Lake is always a
good time I got [__] on hotels because
it was All-Star week but uh I mean it
says he's here
yeah so where'd you stay off of like a
Hilton Garden Inn or whatever yeah it
was like it was like 500 plus
[Applause]
[Music]
free coffee yeah that's about it that
was a veter so we didn't want that free
coffee yeah he wanted that he wanted
that Starbucks next door yeah yeah damn
yeah great club though great Keith
you're the man love Keith uh great Club
great guys and I I just added all these
California dates so I'm pumped I got
like you know uh coming up like San
Diego La sack and SF so that's gonna be
like a fun stretch in April so I'm like
pumped that's fun and we got the bus
coming up in March so it's like 11
straight nights you know beautiful the
bus is the best I love it going up that
Golden Coast with a bus can't beat it
gonna be great gonna be great and I love
San Diego oh we're not doing the bus for
that show because oh it's for four
nights we're doing the bus from like
Miami back to New York so we're coming
from Florida basically back here I see
but that's gonna yeah we're hitting all
those fun places like it'll be like uh
starting in Miami ending in Port Chester
but we're hitting like DC Charleston
Atlanta Miami Orlando all that [__] yeah
damn that's a big it'll be yeah every
night work in DC
it's gonna be great love it man that's
Wilkes Berry I'm lucky I got veteran in
that nice little window dude it's gonna
be he's such a good you need a good
hanging yeah Wilson Vince is coming is
he I was like I might be able to give
you some time he's like I just want to
be there all right I [__] love him
dude he's gonna come on the Pod more
yeah he's so fun we were riffing last
night it was like we were we were every
once in a while it goes off the rails
but we were in the zone oh yeah it's
good when it clicks yes yes you get that
video uh-oh hey
keep it natural
oh yeah
look at this guy oh you want to make
this guy a cocktail by any chance do you
want anything
uh what do you uh vodka guy
oh yeah even better for Digger cat
oh he can't make that he's 11 years old
can you can you make one oh all right
great just get the man some ice I'm good
good to see you man thanks for having me
appreciate it I almost wore that shirt
and I'm glad I did there you go I made a
million of those that's a rep I had to
rep how you doing man I've been good how
you guys doing good good uh I'm a little
sick but I'm pushing through all right
is it is it the vid what do you got no
no just from pushing it too hard we did
we added a 4 30 show in Spokane and we
went out the night before I mean the
amount of traveling you do too yeah
they're on the road all the time eight
hour eight hour travel day yesterday
people need to understand the commitment
it takes to continue drinking when you
work yes Mark's got the great bit about
the functioning alcoholic about how they
deserve more credit than the the sober
guy yeah because Mark's you know that
bit where he's like [__] you I slept
here yeah that's how I feel about all
those people are bragging online about
being sober all the time like it's been
842 days since I last I'm like you did
nothing
your life is better you quit actually
yeah you're a quitter and it's easy to
wake up sober it's healthier it's the
way to be yeah very it's boring that's
the problem it is well I'm like a weed
fit I feel like uh that to me is like
sort of a good middle ground of like
your body isn't like chewed up all the
time like alcohol all the time it's
rough on you but you do like Ayahuasca
and [__] too that's what once a year uh
I just did it a couple weeks ago I do it
maybe like uh two to four times a year
wow that's a lot thanks well there's so
much involved that you gotta go to it
Shaman and a Hut in South America you
could do it in uh not South America too
oh okay but uh also there is like what's
hard is like the three days before and
the three days after no caffeine no
alcohol whoa no weed no fried foods what
uh just to get the full impact I mean
you could but it's just going to dilute
it and like you know if you know the
fried foods yeah yeah they're oh they're
holistic and natural about you know so
what do you eat like going in like
vegetables and you know you can do fish
steamed things so Ayahuasca actually
makes you healthier just in general
because you have to be to go with it
yeah I mean it's not like a party drug
it's it's like medicine you're gonna do
some work afterwards you're like oh [__]
I gotta like do yoga and change my life
right you know like and everything toxic
I've been doing well Neil Brown and then
you forget about it and you go back to
all your [__] right and then you gotta
do Ayahuasca again yeah it's like a nice
reset yeah it's it's definitely like the
reset but I had a woman once tell me
it's like 10 years of therapy and and
one wow which sounds horrible well
that's it there is a lot it's like a
line that people use and like the
closest I got I went to my therapist
after the first time of doing Ayahuasca
and she was like I'm really amazed at
the breakthroughs you've had from doing
it almost like she felt not that she
felt bad but she's kind of like a little
bit of like you know what we've been
meeting every [__] week for like five
years and you go you do this plant for
like one weekend and all of a sudden you
learned all this [__] I've been trying
to explain to you that's a bit well
because therapists can't tell you what
are the good ones anyway don't tell you
what to do they're always just kind of
hinting so you figure it out for
yourself yeah just tells you what to do
does your therapist tell you God yeah
he's absolutely been like you need to do
this and I don't want to and he's like
do it I'm like all right you listen you
pay attention yeah he wanted me to suck
him off
uh no he no he tells you what to do all
the time it's a
it's not good yeah I know same guy and
it's usually good advice though I know
but it's definitely the problem is when
they encourage you to confront people is
that they're not always it's not always
going to help the relationship totally
certain people I think you have to
accept with their flaws and there is a
part of his philosophy that's like no
this person needs to hear that and I'm
like but they're not doing this type of
work on themselves so they're it's not
gonna yeah it's gonna destroy the
relationship it's a good point I think
in general this is the thing for being a
truth teller is really venerated in our
society but if you go around doing it
people don't like you yeah it's not a
good way it's not beneficial to you in
your life to go around telling the truth
to people you like do I look fat in this
yeah there's your marriage right there
this haircut
get out of here with the truth the truth
is overrated
but like going back to the therapist I
think my there I guess I assumed all
therapists were this way I think her
theory is that like if she just tells me
what to do it won't actually stick so
I've got to figure it out for myself or
at least be fooled into thinking like I
decided it right you know but yeah I
don't know if that's right or not Neil
Brennan said he got Chris Rock to do it
and now Chris Rock is religious
oh is it Neil Brennan says he's fat he
believes in God really yeah
although I do think like going backwards
to me well we get into what is God it's
like are you I don't think either one of
these guys are like cheap who are just
like obeying no or like some preachers
telling them to do or that'd be funny if
it just made Rock boring
seriously I mean there are a lot of
these Wellness people who you're like
what happened you've been new you're
like you've been neutralized totally
totally I think both those guys still
have like strong opinions but just like
do you believe in like a bigger
spiritual force or something that's you
know kind of controlling the universe
it's not just your own ego that makes
sense there is something when people
walk around too happy that I'm like are
you [__] dumb yeah that's not healthy
either to just make to just make an
assumption about someone because they
don't seem miserable well this was like
a Socrates asked that is it better to be
like a pig that's satisfied or a genius
dissatisfied yeah that's why that's why
I'm a pig the best is when everybody's
full of [__] you know like like Ellen is
dead dancing every episode but then you
hear like oh she's a huge Coos uh when
behind the scenes and I love that I love
when it that they uh like Cosby Cosby's
the America's dad pull your pants up put
a sweater on Jello pop and then you know
look at him the more you got to perform
something constantly the more suspicious
it is exactly like the guys who got the
big gauge earrings
you're [__] uptight and then the dude
is always wearing the suit and [__] I'm
like this guy's into some kinky [__]
yeah the priest the priest [__] the
kids yeah if your whole life is about
like look at also it's like like with
the religious people anyway like people
who behave in a religious way impress me
people who talk a lot
well go volunteer at a [__] soup
kitchen then then I'll believe it there
we go we start on the God hates [__]
guys they're all blowing each other
that's true so many so many end up like
all these sets don't get him started
he'll go I mean I have the merch
yeah it's so to the overcompensation
it's uh like you see this Chelsea
Handler video that's going around no oh
it's like super viral about her she's
like
here I am being a woman with no kids in
my 40s I think I'm going to smoke weed
then masturbate then go back to bed wake
up at noon then fly to Paris then get
drunk then meet a hot guy on Raya and
she's like if I had a kid I wouldn't be
able to do any of this and all these
angry moms are like [__] you you're sad
you're dead inside you're [__] whatever
and it's causing a lot of stir with the
with the with the women who cares yeah
I'm not on any side but I do think it's
a little Pokey she's poking like hey you
idiot ladies like someone went after her
like some Tucker Carlson guy whatever
just start it or whatever right right A
lot of people went after her but there's
pressure on women to like you know just
give in and have kids and I think it's
not for everybody I think totally
there's no idle pressure that's just
like well does everyone need a family I
think a lot of people you see them on
flights all the time like this person
doesn't want a family no but they were
they felt they should yeah and now we
have two kids with a mother who's
[__] miserable and drunk on the
flight agreed I think my parents are in
that boat
a lot of people have no like purpose in
life and they think having a child will
like fill a great hole and then they
have a child they're like no but I think
I guess this is a purpose but I don't
like it but people are saying she's over
compensated the whole thing we talked
about like she's really she thinks now
doth protests yeah Elena real thick so
you're like maybe you do okay that
that's the I just feel like we're all
generating content like we're talking
about it like Tucker Carlson what does
he even believe you know right they
don't believe the election stolen but
they go on air and say it was oh yeah
they they make fun of her for being like
some you know lonely shrew and then
she's gonna be like oh you're wrong yeah
what are we all doing I'm sure if you
took every Fox News and every CNN person
behind the scenes got him drunk or like
do you believe all this they'd be like
I'm just trying to keep my job you know
I gotta pay them Don lemon's a fan of
yours how about that yeah right when he
comes out as a fan he gets canceled
we're we're listening to YouTube we're a
gateway to getting you [__] over
you're [__] you're too influenced Don
Lemon like he was you know doing the the
anti-woke stuff and I'm just like that
keep your job dude yeah I play ball this
works on YouTube this doesn't work on
CNN yeah come on here we'll talk about
it we'll talk to someone that's sweet
cancel culture buzz it works well you
saw salad he's posted we'll do Don
lemoncellos
you gotta have them on right I would
love to have mods yeah sure
those are free apparently right now so
he's got some free time yeah well it's a
silly thing to say like what was the
exactly I didn't actually hear it so
maybe it's out of context because I feel
like so much stuff but he said that
women after 40 are not in their Prime
anymore as politicians I'm like are you
talking about fertility or politics what
are we talking about right you know and
they were like what do you mean Don he's
like no no I'm just saying she's clear
or not and it probably kept going with
it yeah in her prime is it just stay
away from that yeah I think with the
ladies
yeah that's tough you know it's like
being telling your black friend hey
you're whipped
all right there you go don we're even
all right spring cleaning is here boys
time to clean out those nasty holes oh
yeah manscape performance package 4.0
has it all the lawnmower 4.0 body
trimmer the weed whacker nose and ear
hair trimmer your hair we got some old
listeners you need that tell me I'm
looking at here in the library
trim it feature proprietary Advanced uh
skin safe technology to protect your
delicate parts and holes yeah I trim
with this stuff and it's scary putting
the razor to your shaft but I'm not
scared when I'm using this [__] yeah
right my ball sack like hey we've all
had that fear you know you bleed out the
little fluid comes out of your ball sack
not with this stuff you got that right
the package also comes with their crop
preserver ball deodorant because he gets
smelly down there yep and crop reviver
ball toner smell as clean as a baby's
Bungholio always use the right tools for
the job head to their website and check
out all their tools to help you upgrade
your hygiene routine get 20 off and free
shipping with the code drunk at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use code
drunk manscaped your balls will thank
you here here
hey folks drink zbiotics
you know it you love it you can't afford
to waste a day stuck on the couch
because of a few drinks the night before
zebiotics is the answer we've all been
looking for zebiotics pre-alcohol pro
biotic is the world's first genetically
engineered probiotic uh it was invented
by PhD scientists to tackle rough
mornings after drinking here's how it
works when you drink alcohol oh when you
drink alcohol gets converted into a
toxic byproduct in the gut it's this
byproduct not dehydration that's to
blame for your rough day zebiotics
proves an enzyme to break this byproduct
down it's designed to work like your
liver but it's in your gut where you
need it most drink zebiotics before
drinking alcohol drink responsibly and
get a good night's sleep to feel your
best tomorrow
give zebiotics a try for yourself go to
zebiotics.com drunk to get 15 off your
first order when you use code drunk at
checkout thank you C-Max is back with
100 money back guaranteed so if you're
unsatified for any reason they'll refund
your money no questions asked remember
to head to ZBOX drunk and use code drunk
at checkout for 50 off thank you
zebiotics responding this episode
it works yeah
yeah fitbot is a new app that creates an
exercise program around your goals
equipment and schedule it's the easiest
way to work out hey man we're all trying
to get fit oh yeah look we take horrible
cares of ourselves cares that's how
hungover I am I just have cares instead
of care we take bad care of ourselves
we're trying to get fit we're trying to
stay in shape here so you know we don't
feel bad I don't know I feel terrible
right now fitbod varies your routine for
you to avoid over training way cheaper
than a personal trainer fitbot is easy
to use on both IOS and Android devices
their video tutorials make it easy to
learn a new routine you can get a full
year personalized workouts with fitbod
for less than the cost of one session
with a personalized trainer join fitbot
today and build a routine that grows
with you without slimming down your
wallet 25 off your subscription or try
the app for free when you sign up now at
fitbod.me drunk that's
fitbod.me slash drunk nice
uh yeah that's uh those shows so much
talking and yeah it's an Around the
Clock news you gotta say something about
all TV news like anyone who watches I'm
like what are you doing with your life
it's too much what are you doing it's
also
for the most part most news is like
subscription based now too which is like
yeah almost newspapers you know
especially so it's like you're just kind
of pandering yeah or those sub Stacks
where you people are literally paying
you like whatever 80 bucks a year to
tell so you tell them what they want to
hear yeah like where are the incentives
like you know going back to being a
truth teller like you're going to tell
everyone who subscribes to your [__]
while they're like dumb and wrong or you
know how to feed them what they want to
hear and now you're in a bubble now you
regurgitate everything you agree with
and no one gets anywhere and we just
start separating more and more because
if you don't agree with me completely
we're not cool the problem is like MSNBC
is like the the left one fox is the
right one and then CNN like you'd want
to think they're kind of in the middle
but they're just kind of left too of
course in the middle it's a dumb place
to be from a business course of course
but now you have two that are on the
left that are major and that of course
takes away from each other yeah and then
the one on the right has the highest
rate that you guys right Newsmax or own
you ever tune into one of those are much
smaller yeah
I talked to someone who said they were
offered a position there and she was
like [__] that [__] it's like hardcore
cult stuff for sure really well I don't
know just like do you believe in the do
you want the truth from your news or you
want to be like yeah [__] those right
right what's a thin line now right I
mean it's uh it's it's not really news
if it's on that much right it's It's
Entertainment the news used to be like
once a day and it was like one person
you're like I trust this person now it's
like 14 people I mean same in sports
like yeah ESPN it's all just like two
dudes arguing about like LeBron versus
MJ like did anyone play an actual game
can we watch that I know right well
that's that's what they do because and
it's like arguments you could tell they
don't even really believe but it's like
the way we'll just kind of like Riff on
something for the sake of the joke but
they're doing that with like journalism
yes you know yes everything's become
wrestling
20 minutes ago that's so funny there it
is it's all pro wrestling because you
need the ratings you need the heal you
need the hero yeah see Colin uh what's
his name
Howard Skip Bayless oh yeah yeah throws
it uh Cowboys jersey in the trash it's
like this is a total wrestling movie
this is a wrestling yeah yeah yeah and
it's 71 it's like it's comical to be a
71 year old man to be like oh yeah well
just to get back to the news thing how
crazy is we undervalued like newspapers
the actual physical form of a newspaper
forced you to read [__] you didn't want
to click on right yeah show up on the
next page you'd be like I guess I have
to learn about this and then the opinion
stuff was all on like two pages in the
back and you knew this was the opinion
stuff yes and the rest of the newspaper
was news and there was no name yeah not
by a person it was just this is the New
York Times and now the New York Times
that's like 40 opinion pieces every day
and then they're like why don't people
trust us I'm like well you stop doing
the news you just offered up a bunch of
opinions and now people are dumb they
can't tell the difference they think
you've got an agenda but they need
subscribers that's the thing is like
they'll ever you could tell they're like
kind of crying poor every New York Times
podcast they you listen to it there's
like a little guilt no for sure they're
like this isn't free guys we need them
in the Washington Post are the only two
survivors too so like they're if they're
doing that like imagine what happened to
the Chicago Tribune or all these like
other small town papers and then the
worst thing the most dangerous thing is
people go but this is just my truth and
you're like wait wait wait we need to go
not true but this is my truth then
you're like what and then if you argue
with them you're a big hit or this is my
lived experience I love that one it's
like isn't every experience live you
think there's some zombies out there
like we've all had experiences that
doesn't mean yours is the one true way I
know but by the way the one I actually
want to hear is a Como experience that's
the one you actually want to hear about
what happened when you were in a coma no
one talks yeah did you get diddled by
the dock did you did you hear things do
you remember when you're in a coma
though I don't think so no interesting I
remember the Tony Soprano coma episode
yeah that was great yeah remember that
weird one Carmella came in she's like oh
Toady and when you were 15 you beat up
that guy at the ice cream stand that was
so hot I never got that
[Music]
two of the best comedians working and I
well here's what I think people don't
always factor in like the the volume of
stuff that you guys are putting out like
the frequency
well there's like I think there's a lot
of people who put out like a good
special like every like three years or
something like that like the amount that
you guys are generating and the quality
of it I think is like so [__]
impressive to everything else that
you're doing so I just wanna
comedian I feel like you guys are kind
of set in the bar for where where people
can be and whatever you got the bar
right but and we're drinking throughout
the whole thing and we're doing a
podcast and I'm getting married and he's
gay now so we're very busy I mean I
always work doing this to turn me I
can't wait for the burnout to happen I
can't wait for it all to crash and
burned out the truth oh it's gonna be
ugly yeah yeah you know it's the
Chrysler model when that falls it's
gonna fall hard when they find her name
on those Epstein flight logs but until
then amongst a great group Bill Gates
Tucker yeah we wish Jesus Christ real
thinkers there's a lot of thinking going
on there's some good conversations I bet
definitely now that's the podcast
uh the Lolita podcast
I Heart Radio
I heart teens all right but thank you I
appreciate it well I feel like you got
to capitalize when you're hot yeah it's
all it's all going to go away at some
point the Fizzles use that momentum yes
so that's what I remember opening for
Jim Jeffries like years ago it's
probably like 2011 or something remember
this [__] yeah we went out after with a
party with him after so fun but I
remember at the end of the weekend he
sold out every show I just watched him
take a long drag of a cigarette and he
goes I'll see this place on the way back
down ah sums it all up well like I have
a buddy of mine's a booking agent for
like rock bands I used to talk about
that too of like you see these people go
up and some of them they treat everyone
like [__] as they're going up and he's
like I'm just telling you I've seen this
before you're coming back to these same
people again in the future make sure who
you who you treat well and who you don't
totally we've all been doing it long
enough to see some of those people kind
of get humbled already where you know
you see those people you're like I
remember people being such a such a dick
oh yeah even at that age I was like you
know this is not the right move right
well I feel like that Joan Rivers doc
was a great examination of what a real
career is like yeah it's not all you can
have the most heat for like a few years
but a real career for decades is always
going to have ups and downs and you you
got to like factor that in and realize
that if you're you're in it for the long
haul yeah Patrice called it the roller
coaster he's like sometimes you're up on
the top of that that uh you know that
drop and it's so fun and then you gotta
get back in line and that's when your
show's not getting picked up auditions
are gone you're bombing your your
tickets aren't solo but then you get
back up and then it's all though maybe
that's changed now because we can
connect with people in that direction
you had to like for years it was like
you got to go through this Maze of like
these industry people like now if you
just stay connected to your fans I
wonder if if there is a smoother
trajectory I think you're right I think
you're a podcasting it's a it's a one A
to B you go right to them but I do think
I'm scared of younger Comics now like
when I was coming up I feel like I just
wasn't allowed to talk like if I was
around a bunch of bigger comics and I
spoke they'd be like why is he talking
and you're like okay sorry now if I'm
around a bunch of younger I'm like
blowing them like Kurt Metzger had a
great point he's like when you when I
started I was super nice to the industry
because I wanted to get stuff now I'm
very nice to Young Comics so they don't
like tweet about me and [__] and I'm
like that's so true it's kind of flipped
because they'll just go on like a face
thing and be like uh Matt Ruby farted on
me in a green room I'm just saying what
happened to me
and uh Mark Norman farted on me on a
podcast it's out there if you want to
see it don't [__] him
so he made this jerk off motion
throughout the party the other thing was
somebody said back in the day a club
used to book the features now the
headliner books the features and that's
very true well that would happen early
on they'd be like we and I always
respect clubs that like we have our own
culture and we're trying to build a
culture here too but at the same time
you know like when we're on the road
every week I need to have someone I know
with me not just for my sanity but I
know it's going to be a good show yes
yes depending on you know you have your
culture yeah it's sort of like my
culture matters too and this is my show
that I want people to come back to and I
need a killer opener for that show sure
sure good point yeah it's a different
time but I heard one comic big comic not
gonna say his or her name but they were
like I'm think I'm gonna fire my manager
and I was like well you've been with
your manager 40 years you're huge and
he's like I make so and so Millions
I make 44 million a year or whatever the
[__] he makes yeah what does that mean
they get 4 0.4 million every year wow
that's insane they get 10 of my giant
check internet detectives get on it I'm
just like why do I have to give them
that yeah and then you fired yours so
like years ago I haven't imagined in a
long way and you're doing fine yeah you
miss it anything about it not at all wow
not a peep I have a tour manager on the
road now and and he does a shitload so
it like I I see what he does and then he
you know puts money back in my pocket he
does stuff yeah that makes sense and
he's great I I don't really I'm sure
there's stuff that there are good
managers out there but I've never seen
it but no one gives a [__] about this
talk at home
but it goes back to the business
changing is what I'm saying yeah the
internet the pods the clips it's all
direct totally yeah so you did a special
where you're on a different drug in
every in every so it's four four sets
one high on weed one drunk one on
shrooms and one sober four weeks apart
film back to back yeah directed by our
boy Mancus did an amazing job directing
it the cues love them appreciate them
what what he did that was really
valuable for the whole thing was like
kind of push it because we did
documentary stuff leading up to each
show to push it to be like let's get a
little deeper let's get a little more
philosophical let's talk about like
these substances and you know making art
and Performing and how it all interacts
with each other in a way that I don't
think out of the gate I was like super
comfortable with but like he kept
pushing for it and I think in the end
it's part of what people are responding
to is because it's like it's funny it's
interesting to see these substances but
then you also get like a little behind
the scenes of like what are you trying
to do on stage who are you trying to
beat do you want to be polished do you
want to be scripted and rehearsed or do
you want to just be in the moment and
loose and like are you best when you're
a little bit like you know [__] up are
you best when you're like completely
sober what's what does the audience want
yeah like what do you what's the real
goal here at the end of all this and so
I think a lot of that stuff came out
that's the that's the best when you get
a little deeper and what also took balls
is most people do a special they go hey
I'm doing a special I'm doing an hour
come on out you did this in front of
random New York audiences they had no
idea what was going to happen until the
the host brought me up and told them the
concept but so told them the four
substances but didn't tell them which
one I was on and so I just go up and I
kind of had to like navigate that out of
the gate so yeah it was like a little
bit of like this experiment of okay
let's try this and yeah the highs were
great like spoiler alert like the shroom
set was probably like my favorite one
the silver one was probably like the
best me as best immediately and the
drunk one was like so awful that for
like a week afterwards I was like being
like what the hell am I doing like wow
I'm paying money to film people to have
people film me be bad at the thing that
I want the world to think I'm good at
wow
I wanted to be legally drunk so I
brought a breathalyzer and I was and
then they gave me Shots before I went on
and brought me a drink on stage and then
I didn't remember anything I said during
the set until the next day I had to
listen back wow
wow it was The Hangover
of like oh my god what the hell did I
just do yeah oh man and like it was like
uh we edited in a way that it's
compelling filming yeah I'll say this
about myself even when I was [__] up I
was like I don't think that was a good
set but it was a good good filmmaking
good footage so I knew that even when I
was messed up but I did not feel good in
that room in like I don't think I did a
good job I broke the contract between
yeah yeah and performer but you did it
for the sake of getting a professional
yeah have you ever gone on that drunk
before this not that not never that
drunk that high I've done like I've
smoked a joint or had a couple drinks
but never anything like this part of it
was like I can't just go on having two
drinks and act like that I don't know
like you gotta go for it good for you do
it so how many drinks do you think it
was
I think it was like eight drinks in an
hour or something like that no no meal I
just got it off a flight from Memphis
where I'd done a corporate gig I didn't
eat like I was just talking to me at all
uh was it that week oh yeah we hung out
we [__] I knew my ass was sore
we chatted before and you were you were
like we were like cartoons oh wow yeah I
was cartoonishly drunk yeah which
usually I'm like not I'm like was there
a set you were trying to hit or was it
yeah but like uh drunk I forgot to tell
jokes
completely I told like two jokes in like
a 20-minute set how much of that made
the special uh I mean yeah like like 10
10 to 12 minutes from the drunk set in
what order is that one in that's second
so first one's High then's drunk then
shrooms and then sober so you close with
your two favorites yeah I think also I
figured out what was happening in the
project oh in the beginning I was just
like let's see what happens and also
after the drunk one there was like a lot
of pressure internally totally like
totally I better [__] deliver on like
shrooms and sober because like I really
[__] [__] the bed on this drunk one
and the shrooms one was also it's like I
like doing shrooms I can talk on shrooms
and we got to like some I had some good
jokes and then I also talked about some
deeper stuff about like my mom and New
York City and death and reincarnate
shroomy stuff but like still like fun
and captivating and then the sober one
was good because I was like oh finally I
can actually it's like when you've been
swinging a bat with the weight on it for
like you know and then I got to go out
and swing like a normal bed I was like
oh yeah I would like to perform yeah
sober I'm I'm at the peak of my power
yeah exactly the shrooms I mean is that
are you in control when you're on
shrooms on stage or or no I am I mean I
you know I think there's how much did
would you take you could take an amount
where you're not in control I think I
was like right in that line of still
also like for me I've done shrooms a lot
so I feel like I'm pretty competent and
can like you know handle my [__] and
talk
um but I think uh yeah for a lot of
people I don't know if I'd advise it no
I've done Awards it sucks
because you want to just be high or do
stand up they're not good together well
I'll tell you what I saw which even
comes up is like the difference between
like the drunk one and the shrooms one
like the drunk when you're drunk it's
all ego it's all like everything I'm
saying it's interesting uh like right
it's almost like how they feel doesn't
matter because it's all about you and
then the shrooms one was all was like no
ego it's like oh how I feel doesn't
matter at all we're all connected and
all this shroomy stuff like how do we
have a good time together what's funny
for us as a group in this way that's
like uh to me was like really
interesting and enjoyable but the drunk
one was sort of like I thought I was
doing great yeah I thought like yeah
they want me to stay on stage even
longer yeah they had to come get me off
stage alcohol silences the voices in
your head that you should be listening
some of those voices other people like I
got voices in my head well are they
right yeah if they're right maybe you
should be listening what's also
interesting too is every other
performance I think drugs help you know
performance enhancing drugs steroids all
this [__] with asthma leads and singers
but with us I think they hurt yeah I
think cocaine or booze or Adderall even
I think it hurts your performance I feel
like caffeine are we counting that as a
drug caffeine's may be okay yeah
caffeine I missed my six cup of coffee
oh wow I need caffeine I think it helps
you right maybe yeah but I think being
on stage sober with a full night's sleep
does nothing better yeah yeah that's
true I think I need I need some coffee
but uh that's interesting you talked
about your mom I mean I remember you
wrote something years ago on Facebook
about it was beautifully written about
your mom thanks uh it was it was moving
and then she was like a very artsy woman
yeah well so like uh another spoiler
alert but like this is from doing this
special like my mom lived in the same
house as like Lou Reed and John kale and
The Velvet Underground and like the last
side and I knew about that but I didn't
know until filming the special I had
Googled some stuff I was like oh I
should talk about that because she threw
this event her and this other guy Angus
called rights of the dream weapon and I
had found a flyer online and the address
on the flyer was 85 East 4th Street
which is New York comedy club wow oh
that's where you filmed it yeah and so
then I was like oh I gotta look this up
and see if I can find out anything else
about it and I found this site where
like Sterling Morrison started talking
about how like uh he bumped into Lou and
Angus on the street and they all decided
to perform at this event which was this
rights of the dream weapon show at 85
East 4th Street and then I scrolled up
the very first Velvet Underground
performance ever Sterling Morrison Lou
Reed John kale and Angus mcclees
produced by my mom in that space at 85
East 4th Street where I filmed the
special and I found out about all that
because I filmed the special there so
it's like to me that's the kind of [__]
that like you start you start doing
shrooms or Taking Chances or being like
let's piece some stuff together and then
all of a sudden the universe just sort
of like hands you something wow your mom
blew Lou Reed
the drummer Angus
I came home one
from college listening to The Velvet
Underground she just stopped she's like
are you listening to The Velvet
Underground I was like yeah she's like I
used to live with them I was like that's
insanity and and then I'm like were you
a fan and she's like oh we thought they
were like too commercial like they were
all listening to like Lamont young and
these like people in Lofts doing like a
half hour of Silence with like five
minutes and [__] that was way more
avant-garde yeah like what do you like
like Angus who's the original drummer in
the velvets quit because this is
literally his lines like no one's ever
gonna tell me when to start and stop
playing drums
okay well we're gonna get someone else
yeah yeah NWA
[Laughter]
that's where it is
but uh yeah man that's hilarious The
Velvet Underground that's incredible
it's incredible story well it's also
about New York City and like that
neighborhood and like what's going on
like even though it's all condos and a
bunch of [__] now there's still
something in the streets oh The Villages
still comes from like you know cbgbs and
the velvets
cbgb's too but uh that's crazy about uh
she dated the drummer for how long I
toured uh she hitchhiked through like
Europe and Asia with him wound up
hanging out with Leonard Cohen in a cave
in Greece like the the week The Beatles
album came out I was like yeah my mom
was like more interesting than I'll ever
be my whole life is just trying to like
uh come in second place man yeah that's
where I first found out about Ayahuasca
is I think his documentary he did it oh
yeah and that's why I found out you puke
from that and you uh Purge yeah people's
number one fear about it yeah right is
that why you wouldn't do it puking he's
never done shrews no I don't I don't
like it with that I'd like to push how
do you know you don't like it if you
have a choice I don't know I don't like
getting [__] in the butt by a dude
I've never tried that all right all
right well you know but you're not
curious about that no okay maybe curious
about the shrooms not that curious
either way a mushroom head's going in
you all right
uh I just uh man maybe I should try Marx
there's never a time I'm feeling like I
never have a day off and then whenever
day off like what am I gonna experiment
no I get the same reason I don't go on a
[__] date it's like first of all take
a day wait what's the reason you don't
go out on date just like I'm home two
days a week you know and then I you know
one of those nights I could be at the
cellar both of the both those nights but
say one of those nights you know I go on
a date what if the date sucks I've just
wasted half my week what what what are
you afraid of if you took a day off
or two days off God forbid I don't know
something's wrong with me I I definitely
Mark and I before you came here I was
yeah I was like I have a night off and
then as someone just texts me to do
their show and I said should I do it
Mark's like you should do it and I said
all right I'll do it I figure it's 15
minutes you'll still have the night but
you got 50 minutes of work in you'll
feel better
yeah you can do a whole night off well I
mean on some level it's almost like if
you're that afraid of it it almost seems
to me like maybe you should try it like
it's like take a week off just to be
like what what happens if I do this it's
a great idea I'm gonna go skydiving
without a shoes
I'm scared of that too
true but one will kill you
yeah how many dissatisfied customers are
is there like a Yelp for Ayahuasca
yeah I think it's Vice news
they just find anyone who's ever been
assaulted or fell off a cliff it's like
this is what happens all right it makes
me I mean I'm sure like honestly I would
be more scared of booze than I would you
know mushrooms sure for sure I've just
been drinking since I was so young right
right well then it's fine
well keep it up find something that's
killing you slowly that you're
comfortable with yes yes we'll get
married
I mean I just shrooms at my wedding to
me shrooms like amplify it brings things
more happy yeah so I like them for me
it's a staying single yeah but that
makes sense too I get both of them well
I like I think don't do anything that
you don't want to do but the the
self-examination that I would encourage
is like is this coming from is it coming
from a place of fear is it coming from a
place of ego coming from a place of like
being a control freak or is it coming
from like actually like no that's just
not right probably control freak so it's
like is that and is that working for you
in a way that you want to like you know
yeah
or are you like is it yeah if you're if
it's working keep doing it if not like
challenge it I'd say well said I'll
start with shrooms maybe I think you'll
I think you would love shrooms and you
could drink while you do it also but
really yeah the thing that I'll say is
do it with people you like and in a
setting that you like and with a mindset
where you're in a good vibe because like
these everyone always was like I had a
bad trip you're like oh did you do it at
a music festival with 18 people you
don't know and then you couldn't find
your tent and you like oh yeah how did
you know I'm like because this is every
[__] bad trip story is exactly the
same like that sounds awful to me yeah
yeah a nightmare going a burning man is
a gateway to talking about burning man
also like people try to get me to go to
Bernie man a lot because I think I'm
like a burning man it sounds interesting
I will say it does my well as a Jew I
think to return to the desert
voluntarily
and then also just anything that's like
well it's ten thousand people all I'm
like right there right there the older
you get the more I'm like [__] big
groups yeah yeah
we're going to Coachella I'm like oh
that's a young man's game but I will say
I went to Bonnaroo and I was probably
like 28 and me and Michelle wolf did
shrooms and we had a [__] blast she
described you as like a weird cat yeah a
weird cat because Mark would think like
a jazz what we would like no like Mark
would just like disappear and then show
up but she'd be like Mark yeah I
remember her telling me about it yeah I
did Bonnaroo once too and it was I
didn't do drugs I just did a show yeah
it was fun yeah amazing bands there but
again we had the Pampered Hotel
trailer just being in a tent and there's
mud and like the I just watched too many
Woodstock documentaries to ever want to
do anything like any of those totally I
get it but
it was fun as a youth but you're going
back this the dust and all that well
even I feel the same way about like
political rallies even like I went to a
bunch of like the black lives matter
rallies like the megaphones always go
into some guy yeah I don't think this
guy should be Amplified I know right I
like it's gonna work on his rally yeah I
don't murder George Floyd but also I'm
opposed to slam poetries
where do I get to go to support yeah
like I'm always like any type of
political rallies where there's like 5
000 people chanting the same thing I'm
like I'm check it out yeah they always
throw in one at the end that you're like
I was with the first three yeah yeah
free Palestine you're like come on I'm
right here
it's uh whenever it gets there's always
one at the end yeah there's like a group
of like white chicks who are like in
their 20s like cursing out some cop and
telling them to suck their dick and I'm
like this is the height of white
privilege
yeah you're not making black people feel
better right now yeah helping anyone do
anything yeah yeah that was weird and
you want to go how long are we marching
like I'll do it but just let me know if
it's an hour is it two hours well they
kept Mark's concerned with the
protesters the cardio yes yes yeah I
mean I gotta get my steps in but
just for ten thousand steps and I'm out
of here I would have bought a smart
water if I knew he'd be doing all this
walking I'm just saying well I always
say the most White Privilege thing I
ever did was ask the cop where the
protest was
story I really did that
so yeah it's on YouTube yeah Ruby
substance check it out
make fun of my yellow pants that's what
one guy did fun I saw the uh I saw a few
of them live and we have a couple good
lines in there oh thank you we had a
show we have a show every Wednesday at
the New York Comic of eight o'clock
sells out every week good eggs great
show great show great comment great
lineups and you did it there yeah and
the one that I liked the most was the
high one because you got high out of
your tree yeah this guy was baked and
then you went on and the host goes this
guy's doing a thing where he's getting
high and doing jokes for a special and
the crowd was like oh they were
intrigued and you went on and you had a
smile ear to ear and you went can you
tell
well that's what I love too it's like I
didn't think of that that was like
literally on the way to the stage
from the intro being like oh these are I
know what everyone in this room is
thinking which I think to me is still
probably like the best feeling as a
comic yes everyone in the room is
thinking something and you're the one to
articulate it yeah and they all laugh in
that that moment of like shared
experience and it's funny it's like to
me that's that's still feels like you
broke the tension yeah in a concise way
and now we're all in it together too
yeah I saw Shane Gilla you know he got
canceled SNL whatever and I saw him his
first set back and it's weird it's like
seeing a celebrity because you're like
oh that guy's the biggest thing in the
news right now and he's right there and
then he went on and he thinks the whole
world hates him he's the biggest racist
of all time Clan member and he goes on
the audience is like and he goes
[Laughter]
a lot of this [__] isn't real and you
know we actually kind of like you more
now yeah now he's doing great yeah it
could have been the best thing that ever
happened to him too sometimes you don't
even know about like what's the path
yeah I think Shane was inevitable I
think I think it would have happened
regardless I think if he was on SNL
would have happened I think it you know
it happened this way because I think his
talent is undeniable but I
yeah you never know sometimes that type
of thing
forces you to show us who you are like
he could have gotten bitter he could
have gotten totally mean yeah and
instead he just was like I'm gonna be
funny and I'm gonna really just go
around this and that was I think was the
way to go you know right I mean it's
like when Louie just went on he went you
guys want to talk about it and that gets
a laugh so well he's got a great line in
his new one about it like I know
everyone here there's one person you
didn't tell you were coming I love the
self-awareness too it's so good and the
specificity yeah like I know exactly
where I am I'm doing fine you're all
here I just sold out Master Square
Garden but I used to sell it five nights
of Madison Square Garden so like I know
that there's a change right of course of
course damn five nights
crazy I think he hit the record back
then I think it was 12 sold out shoes
damn insane crazy supposed to be 12 but
I think it was a snowstorm one got
snowed in but I remember talking about
that on Letterman which is crazy also
how valuable is it that he was doing all
like on a business standpoint that he
was like getting all those emails
selling all that stuff his business
infrastructure and like yeah figuring
out the tech and like who needs the
industry less than Louie I know I know
and he he built that for 10 years before
any of this yeah he's pretty innovative
yeah but you know you you're on YouTube
who is it we all are I know that wasn't
that wasn't a Thing YouTube uh I mean it
changed I mean and but you never know
what's the next thing maybe in a little
while YouTube starts pulling the goal
post down that could happen I mean I
think it all we have to be ready for the
next thing always because yeah I always
feel like there's some a voice in the
back of my head it's like I kind of feel
like I'm working for Mark Zuckerberg
yeah like the amount of time I I know
it's for me I know it's a way to connect
it but like the amount of time like I've
had jobs before in my life and the
amount I'm like oh [__] I got I didn't
post it yeah who do I work for right now
well it's for you but I hear what you're
saying and then when you get these posts
that something you put up there is
harmful for the community it does feel
like HR is talking to you like hey could
you not yeah a joke about little people
and you're like it's to make people
laugh what really bothers me is when I
do a Jew joke and I'm like this is
against anti-Semitism right right Nuance
there's no human being able to decipher
sarcasm yeah it's literally an algorithm
yeah we're all and we like but it feels
like they're the Greek gods now of like
okay I don't just give me a thunderbolt
please like don't don't turn me into
stone or whatever I see comments getting
mad at me because the guy who captured
my thing blurred the name Hitler I mean
you still hear me say Hitler right but
he blew it for the captions just because
of these dumb robots that might think
I'm like doing hate speech up right
right and uh and these people like oh
[__] you you [__] I'm like I'm using
this to plug dates I'm not trying to
like you know I know I'm trying to get
eyeballs on it to plug gig well this
whole idea that intention doesn't matter
is like the great especially like as
comedians like it's good for
entertainment when they quote something
I'm like okay did he say it on a comedy
stage to get laughter did he say it at a
clan rally in front of a Burning Flame
because I'm going to judge it two
different ways of course of course like
when you talk about like robots and like
there's no Nuance there's no like like
Humanity to it I know it's not gotta
scale and it's sad when you when they
take you off like when they take a video
away or they Shadow bit whatever the
[__] it is you're like
I didn't realize how much I needed this
it scares the [__] out of you like oh
wow I post right I better behave now I
better behave yeah it's an adult timeout
it is it is and but you're like I gotta
get back on this how long am I gonna
shadow man what's the timeout it's also
like podcast too it's like if you're
talking for like hours upon hours every
week like eventually like come on you
know and I don't think people really
give a [__] but they're like I can use
this uh you know people I don't think
people really like content the way we're
trying to create content their outrage
is content exactly look what he said
yeah it's we live in an attention
economy where everyone's trying to like
Frack your brain stem all the time for
everyone has a drop of attention they
can get out of it and whether it's
through hatred or laughter or whatever
like whatever works just like ah give it
to me attention is the new oil yeah it's
like at the end of the day it's like not
sustainable you think we can't why is
everyone so sad and lonely and depressed
and going crazy all the time what a
coincidence it all happened while we
were on I had a screen for like 18 hours
every day it's a self-fulfilling cycle
because we go I'm sad because of my
phone let me look at my phone yeah to
forget about how sad I am about my phone
well the phone is like uh Prozac or
something that just compresses you know
like the the lows are better but the
highs are lower yeah everything's just
sort of like this this because you don't
have to feel an awkward moment exactly
every time you refresh it it should just
say you're still sad yeah every time you
refresh Twitter it's still sad with a
question mark yeah let me take the paper
yeah that's what's happening all the
time it really is uh it's great for
Awkward Moments it's bad for pretty much
everything else I guess with convenience
it's an idea yeah
Uber these guys with the female like how
do you get around I know but it's bad
for just relating to other humans like
way worse you see I don't understand how
like a kid I mean I had a hard time
paying attention you know what my
grandparents would say before
smartphones yeah can you imagine the
attention
some old person doesn't know how to edit
their stories anymore that's part of
being a human yeah yeah I know you think
they're going to be able to make it
without like being like I gotta gotta
touch my phone yeah and then you chalk
it at your grandfather goes hey Hey
listen up sonny and you chalk it up to
uh he doesn't get it he's old he's out
of touch and you're like yeah but he's
also a human being and you're a human
being and you're not even connecting and
he's gonna die in 10 minutes
yeah well with the language stuff too
like people get so mad at old people all
right you're done it was a false alarm
it was a breather yeah thank you sorry
Mark's growing and by that I mean he now
pushes his farts in my direction as
opposed to the
guestsi face was like just perfect I've
ever decided to post that was great well
done human interaction no phone
I was gonna say like old people then we
get so mad at them for not keeping up
with like the language they're saying
the right thing oh you're so filled with
hate okay boo I'm like this guy just
can't keep up I know like like words
have become fashion like okay you go to
the runway in Paris and know everything
this guy is just buying underwear at
Kohl's and doesn't know anything right
and doesn't know whether queer is a good
word or a bad word to say now because
you [__] changed it up on him like
five years ago like like these old
people are just trying to keep up and
where's your compassion for him being
old or her being old you know like they
can't keep up with every cool word on
Tick Tock the same with trash in them
all these cancer culture people want way
more forgiveness and compassion for
inmates than people have been
incarcerated and like look at the mass
incarceration but then it's like yeah
but this guy said the wrong things like
oh he's got to go away forever I don't
get it like I thought we want compassion
like I agree we gotta be the change you
want to see in the world is like well
yeah just be consistent is all I want
it's a trendy compassion like hey the
climate change hey covert hate this say
that the environment well it's a crazy
uh
mushroom cloud of chemicals in Ohio
what are you gonna do you know like I
had a bunch of guys on a train who gives
a [__] it is literally which one's gonna
get me the most likes yeah I think so
that is what a lot of this like this act
of this woke activism is but uh you know
I mean it's a performance it's a
performance it's good intentions a lot
of it like oh ukrainians are dying all
right but you were also taught that
you're supposed to like that one and not
this one and but then you're like people
are dying in uh Rwanda and you're like I
didn't see a hashtag for that though
yeah you know the slavery in China well
I don't [__] with China so he's like you
don't really care well all the lgbtq
people who like are like free Palestine
I'm like what do you think happens if
you go to Palestine what do you think if
you walk down the streets of Ramallah
and be like I'm a drag
Tel Aviv that's a good way look in your
special yeah on YouTube substance
there's all these sir hey women are less
CEOs who are women all right well she
got her click cut off in Africa well I
don't want to [__] with that all right
so should we [__] with that first before
the CEOs
big to small the lack of consistency if
you ask me thank you no it's uh it is
interesting too and you know words like
fashion they come back yeah you know
that yeah but they come back so it is
hard to keep track of what you should be
saying there's phrases if you stop
paying attention for like a year you're
like latinx what the hell yeah
then you find wait Latin people don't
even like it they don't like it
again this is like the height of white
privilege to be like Latin people I know
how you want to be referred to yeah
that's why I'm naming my bowling team
the Redskins all right because it's
coming back no I haven't I'm doing a bit
about the word queer because like when I
grew up we were taught for like decades
we never said that word queer it's
hurtful it's hateful and then like a
couple years ago it switched now people
like are you a queer Ally I'm like I
don't know this feels like a trick
question
it's like if someone came watches like
do you think we should protect the
retards I'm like I guess
I don't think that's how you're supposed
to say it but maybe I'm the one who's
behind the times I don't know
I'm tardy yeah
it's weird that's still around tardy
yeah
you can you can you can you can sniff
around the words yeah yeah you can't use
the word well there's n wordy Lee you
know that one oh yeah I don't think
anyone can actually say it no but that
was in books and that means yeah it
means uh stingy right well it's like
[__] like no relation to the actual
n-word but no but I think who got fired
for saying it that's right yeah there's
also an angry on fire for saying [__]
in the armor that was ESPN Jeremy Lim
thing yeah now would you think that was
intentional definitely not he would have
to be the dumbest human being ever for
that to be intentional true true or a
real ballsy uh risk taker like let me
see I don't think racists play with I
think they're just I think they're
quieter yeah I think you're right I
think is that burrows got the joke about
like looking both ways
well he's got the great one about uh
Burr's got the great joke where you say
you know black people with the great
idea of putting [__] after it
seriously this [__] white guy look at
this this white [__] this white
[__] oh that's so good so I mean
he's yeah he's that's such a small
thought to Megan is something so funny
yeah he's like such a master going to
those kind of places but keeping you on
his side yeah oh yeah it's amazing he
had that joke where he's like I'm on a
date with a girl or I was out with a
friend of mine and she was like can I
say something racist and he was like
this is going to be awesome which is
such a funny way to go with it because
this will be interesting right right you
know he's not saying he likes racism
he's saying this will be well it's like
can I tell you something I'm not
supposed to say yeah that's the thing we
most want to hear and that's why
comedy's so popular right now well
that's why like all this cancer culture
stuff it is kind of great for us because
we sure we work in the one room where
people can go for the antidote yeah you
got that great joke about like the
Speakeasy of oh yeah you know [__]
yeah side note I love a speakeasy oh
there's something great about a
speakeasy especially New Yorkers yeah
because there's no sign up for you keep
bridging tunnel away
that's true the whole purpose I love a
weird little old-timey any bar that
feels out of place in time like there's
something fun about you it's like Mark
sugar you stepped into a different
dimension and you feel like they
actually care about booze yes right it's
like it's like a portal in Rick and
Morty you feel like you just walked into
a weird green portal yeah and they hand
you like a gimlet and you're like what
the [__] I know it's like uh because on
the road we go I love to drink I love to
go out after the show but every bar is
there's some Irish sports bar where
everybody's income
I love watching The Lumberjack yeah but
like it's not even a game it's just like
1am and we got another Jack competition
it's a lot of dudes like Macho [__]
I hate they dude bumping you with the
bar I'm too old to be bumped dude no
more bad luck I saw your show uh you're
like get me to a dive Barber the problem
is dive bars are going away this they're
so few now there's some good dive bars
they're out there but I love them true
or false uh uh quote unquote real man
should never look at a drink menu
oh I love that I like that like you
should just know what you drink what do
you got to see what this particular
bartender knows how to bake I'm just
curious I think it's curiosity I usually
I mean I usually don't even order off it
but I'm just curious uh-huh yeah why
what I think one reason I'm curious is
that do you have a paper plan on the
menu because Mark and I are obsessed
with these papers they don't they
usually don't but sometimes they do and
I'm like you know it I've had it before
what like uh attaboy you ever been there
like cool Speakeasy in New York I think
they mentioned that there one time oh
yeah good spot oh wow well uh but also
you got to walk up and put your name in
and then like we'll text you in an hour
like I don't understand this impresses
some people but like I'm impressed by
just like efficiency yeah yeah like not
having to go somewhere and come back
right right but you know uh but people
are impressed by that what you go to
you're in a bar what you what are your
like top three drinks I'm a bullet Ryan
soda usually is my like because I know
everybody's got bullet Rye uh and yeah
like oh like usually bourbon of some
sort so old-fashioned or something like
that yeah
um but I'll change it up lately I've
been doing Hendrix and soda I don't like
to be pigeonholed you know I'm saying I
do something for like a year or two like
it's time to mix it up it's fun to have
a whiskey night that's when I have a
tequila night that's what I mean I've
been into Mexico with a hangover ain't
pretty see I feel like it's more it
feels more like medicine than other
booze if you have a good cut interesting
I like I had a mezcount agroni and I
like that yeah that was good pretty damn
good that's Smoky yeah but yeah Dive Bar
it's usually quieter it's usually
emptier and it's usually uh darker
depends on your goals though are you
going there with friends that you just
want to have a conversation about like
you go to like some more swinging place
you might meet people it depends what
you're looking at I guess I'm never
looking to meet there you go so depends
I've had some looking to meet nights I
want to have that moment and and I did
the other night with a friend and it was
it was fun as hell nice but why was it
the moment oh just you know we're just
hanging at a bar and it was uh you know
just you chat with some people people
was fun it was good but the problem is
is you go to out you go out in New York
now uh I don't know when to start with a
standard cocktails 17 right and I like
to have 18 cocktails you know so I'm
like how did my bill get to be 361
dollars well I'm not out drinking it's
insane it's insane it's just this this
and Ice 17 yeah you're paying for the
real estate ah [__] the real estate give
me a fat lady with a c-section scar and
an eye patch and a couple of parts of
her hair missing this is where the end
is still in Manhattan it's still going
to cost a lot of money just cause she's
gross looking doesn't mean uh we can go
out to Queens let's go to like Echo Park
or flushing or something what depends on
the bar too you know but uh in some
places you'll see like happy hour you're
like all right but happy hours are hard
for us to hit unless we just take the
night off that's true that's true but I
love a happy hour I do too you feel like
you're beating the system well people
are still optimistic yeah tonight could
go anywhere yeah like 3am like this is
not a good vibe here now it's true cheap
beer and oysters that's kind of fun oh
the best the best get [__] up I have
to have a spot the oysters on the
crackers oh yeah I don't get oysters oh
Mermaid Lounge has a great happy hour on
Bleaker and McDougall and it's killer
but it's I think it's like three dollar
beers and quarter oysters so I've done
that a few times like mucus that's been
in the ocean I don't get it it's got
some meatiness I love the salty to it or
you just swallow it I swallow love the
brine a little chill in there yeah maybe
a little chew but I I just like eating
something on a shell the ice it's it's
very presentation is nice yeah it does
feel pretty it feels decadent if it was
if you told me it was trash I probably
wouldn't like it yeah how about caviar I
don't get caviar yeah that I don't get
it I like I mean I like like the fish
eggs on like you know but yeah it's not
something I would seek out but I've had
it before but like it's pretty good yeah
but you ever been to a crawfish boil I
don't know
but it's just they pour it out out it's
steaming that's good that's a communal
thing it's communal you got your beer
you're telling stories you're standing
ripping apart animals with other human
beings it's like we're the master race
here we go
you get Nazis someone's gonna do that
someone's gonna clip that yeah we're the
master race yeah it's just me and Marco
citizen species
[Laughter]
yes they're not gonna get the
Crustaceans all over us the mollusks
don't stay at a chance Matt looks like
the Hipster Nazi
all right
all right well folks check out substance
Matt Ruby substance on YouTube give it a
goog you'll find it it's cool it's fun
it's different it's funny the jokes are
still good thank you and you got the
goddamn uh drugs in there there you go
so I don't think anyone's ever done one
of these no it's the first I ever heard
of it so I mean like uh yeah like the
con I'll tell you the jokes are the
thing that I care about the most what I
didn't realize was how much it was going
to be a window into each one of these
drugs because I'm kind of like four
different Comedians and so you can also
like learn something about each one of
those substances just via me as a vessel
trying to perform on each one that's
great yeah all right well check you're
not gonna see anything like it folks so
check it out yeah it's on YouTube right
now give it a give it a watch and uh
you're gonna be anywhere coming up on
the road man uh Arlington Virginia next
week uh got a podcast called kind of a
lot with Matt Ruby you can check that
out uh we got our Good Egg show every
and hot soup every Wednesday hot that
New York comedy club every Tuesday night
hot soup at comedy seller and I think
that's oh I got a newsletter
mattruby.com
yeah yeah so we got uh New Haven Boston
we keep adding in Boston so please come
out Wilbur baby let's go Miami Orlando
Ponte Vedra which I hear is like Naples
2.0
2 Atlanta Charleston DC uh Durham
Charlottesville Norfolk uh [__] all over
wilkesbury Port Chester and we just
added San Diego La Sacramento SF and
there's more coming there's more
Goldstein theater that sounds like the
most Jewish place
and the next item at the Elliott Gould
no a lot of good stuff coming up so we
hope I hope I see you there and more
West Coast dates as well more other
dates everything's coming everything's
gonna be love it get some Bodega cat uh
get some shirts we got sweaters out
there and I'll be all over the road
markdormancomedy.com got new merch queef
uh I got posters up come out to Chicago
I think we might have sold it out but if
we haven't get those tickets quick we
added a Friday and then uh I'm
announcing a theater tour after that for
the summer I think I'm going to
Australia I'm going to UK really doing
it up so uh I'm coming to your town I
swear to God Oxnard in LA and uh Toledo
and Rochester
so Dayton come on by folks we'll see you
all in hell do some Ayahuasca watch the
special
thanks for having me guys I appreciate
it thanks for coming dude good to see
you
[Music]
to lunch here in New Orleans this woman
doesn't look like I remember her and I
get down in the same way
[Music]
foreign